today we're going to talk about the
amazing
immune benefits of garlic especially
during the winter now garlic has been
used for about i don't know 4 000 years
and it's been used for things like
arthritis diabetes
colds malaria tb and the list goes on
and on and on and on louis pasteur
studied
garlic in its antibacterial
properties the ability to kill
pathogenic bacteria during the second
world war when the russians ran out of
their antibiotics guess what they used
as their antibiotic garlic so garlic was
called russian penicillin so garlic has
been thoroughly proven as a therapy to
prevent infection as one of the big
benefits is ranked at the top as having
potent anti-cancer effects and this data
was from the designer food project where
they were studying the effects of cancer
prevention from vegetables now i want to
share some really interesting data from
this book called modern
phytomedicine okay and this is a
fascinating textbook using
plant compounds and chemicals
in medicine so i want to share with you
the chapter on garlic which is quite
amazing you know they should really
teach this in med school unfortunately
when you go through
medical school or pre-med i went through
pre-med i didn't go through medical
school i went through chiropractic
college which is not the same as medical
school but there's a tremendous amount
of data that you have to
learn and i guess the word learn is
probably not appropriate let's just say
you're being force-fed volumes of data
and you're expected to regurgitate that
and somehow pass the tests so
unfortunately it's set up not to
necessarily really
really understand the material because
there's just not enough time to absorb
and play with information and and
evaluate if it's true or not
instead you are flying by the seat of
your pants trying to
memorize and parrot back this
information
on the multiple choice questions and
then when you graduate you have a chance
to maybe
re-evaluate the information and really
learn it apply it make sure it's
valuable make sure it's true and then
really spend the time then things that
you're interested in so you're not
rushing through things but i want to
show you some very valuable things that
you can apply from this to your life
right now
to bulletproof yourself
against
pathogens now most of the studies that
they were done were in petri dishes okay
that's called in vitro and so to be
transparent they did not study in human
bodies however let me explain what they
found so one of the first studies that
they did is they took this little petri
dish
and they filled it with pathogenic e
coli then they sprinkled some garlic
powder over the e coli and they noticed
that within 12 hours all of the e coli
was completely
dead then they compared this with
another petri dish
with e coli and then they put
fresh grated garlic they grated it right
over this petri dish and within 12 hours
all the e coli was completely dead in
another experiment they found that
garlic killed mrsa which is a
antibiotic resistant microbe which is
very very deadly difficult to kill and
you see this in hospitals but garlic was
able to kill this microbe very easily
and another study they found within
three hours
garlic killed
anthrax and you know how pathogenic or
deadly anthrax is it creates some pretty
serious effects but garlic was able to
kill
anthrax they also found that garlic has
a potent effect against viruses
fungus
and
parasites and then they did some
interesting studies on just the odor of
garlic you know little particles that
come off garlic just from the smell now
what gives garlic the smell is a softer
compound called allicin and allicin is
one of the chemicals in garlic that
does its magic for many things not just
infection for
thinning your blood to prevent a clot
for regulating your blood sugars
for killing cancer
for lowering your blood pressure but
they found just having the odor of
garlic not even touching the bacteria
killed the bacteria so think about it
during the winter months if you consume
garlic
and your breath has an odor of garlic
you're actually repelling microbes you
are killing microbes in the air if
you're breathing off these garlic
particles and apparently garlic has
developed
this defense mechanism
for its own survival
over eons of time just like many other
herbs and vegetables like the onion
and horseradish and many of the
cruciferous vegetables as well garlic
has the ability to bind with
organophosphates
which are in
pesticides and detoxify them from your
body
organophosphates really have a
devastating effect on your immune system
they lower your immune system they make
you very susceptible to getting sick and
garlic can help detoxify these chemicals
to help protect your immune system and
as you probably already know when you
get exposed to a virus the complications
from the virus usually occur in people
who have a compromised immune system
whether they have metabolic syndrome or
they're going through a lot of stress
it's really the strength of the immune
system that gets them through these
infections and this is a topic that is
rarely emphasized or focused on now one
of the problems you're going to run into
is the
quality of garlic did you realize that
of all the garlic in the world comes
from china and the problem with that is
that in china they use bleach on garlic
and they use other chemicals to make
this garlic look very very white without
any blemishes or brown spots they also
sometimes grow the garlic in sewage and
garlic is heavily sprayed with
additional chemicals so if you're going
to buy garlic make sure it's locally
grown make sure it comes from a really
good source another question that people
want to know is what about the fermented
black garlic does that have any
advantages and the answer is absolutely
yes there's more antioxidants there's
more nutrients in fermented garlic and
that would be black garlic or
you can ferment garlic in
honey for example now the honey
obviously is not
keto friendly but what i do is i take
the garlic out i'll rinse it it's
already been fermented and i'll eat one
of these a day during the winter and if
you're not familiar with this recipe
i'll put the link down below but it's a
great way to ferment garlic and allow
the microbes to break down certain
chemicals that make it very easy to
digest and to enhance the garlic with
additional nutrients and phytonutrients
now another point i want to bring up is
what about heated garlic what about
powdered garlic well apparently the real
important phytonutrients in garlic
can survive temperatures that are 100
degrees celsius which is 212 degrees
fahrenheit for at least 20 minutes so
these chemicals do survive a good amount
of heat all right so now that you know
about the
power of garlic
let's talk about the power of using
apple cider vinegar check this out
you